madame monsieur bonjour c'est une
tempête d'une rare violence la plus
forte depuis 50 ans qui a frappé la
partie nord du pays cette nuit mais
aussi paris et l'île de france pour les
pour l'instant il est très difficile
d'établir un bilan
il y aurait déjà huit morts en france
peut-être plus et de nombreux blessés
dont plusieurs grièvement
les numéros d'urgence des pompiers de
paris sont indisponibles pour cause de
tempête
le standard de france télécom ayant été
endommagée le trafic aérien a été
interrompu sur les aéroports d'orly et
de roissy des tournées vers lyon et
bruxelles le trafic ferroviaire demeure
également très perturbé dans la région
parisienne les vents avoisiner 150
km/heure et certains quartiers de paris
offrait ce matin un spectacle de
désolation comme ont pu le constater
olivier caroff et feignent au vernis
après une nuit très agitée des pompiers
totalement débordées
ce matin dans paris qu'on les appelle
partout à la fois sur les toits ou des
cheminées se sont écroulés dans les rues
encombrées d'obstacles les plus divers
arbres feux de signalisation panneaux
publicitaires ou echaffaudages par
endroits la tempête a tout arraché ce
cinéma a vu sa façade entièrement
démantibulé et en normandie hier et
c'était comme ça
donc je m'attendais en entendant vont
surfer ce matin je m'attendais à voir là
mais je ne sais pas quand même à paris
c'est avec les murs je pensais serait un
petit peu plus et peu plus souple quand
même des débris comme ceux-ci projetée
par le vent ou grièvement blessé trois
personnes à paris
témoin de la violence de la tempête
l'enseigne du lido projeté à plusieurs
mètres du cabaret par endroits les
rafales de vent ont atteint les 150
km/heure sur les champs elysées les
roues géantes installées pour l'an 2000
ont tenu le coup une chance terrible ça
souffle terrible et les arbres qui sont
tombés des barrières dans tous les sens
pouvait rien faire pour pouvoir jouer
sur la pelouse de relier un festival
international du cirque devait ouvrir
dans deux jours il ne reste pas grand
chose mais on s'active déjà pour sauver
le matériel rescapés ce qui me
réconforte c'est qu'il ya pas de blessé
c'est que évidemment s'il ya du matériel
qui tombe sur la tête des mêmes des
employés ou tout ça on n'a rien
donc merci mon dieu tant qu'il ya pas
mort d'homme gros lot reste une question
de courage et on en a plein des dégâts
aussi dans les aéroports à orly-ouest
l'écroulement de ces plaques de tôle a
nécessité l'arrêt de toute activité
roissy a également dû fermer dans la
plupart des gares parisiennes
on attend que les voix soient débloqués
pour reprendre le trafic en dehors de
paris
le bilan est déjà lourd lui mort face à
cette tempête que certains spécialistes
considèrent déjà comme la tempête du
siècle
les pompiers demandent surtout à ce
qu'on ne les appelle pas pour des dégâts
matériels
leur ligne 18 et le 112 sont
actuellement saturés
élite
c'est en normandie hier et c'était comme
ça donc je m'attendais en entendant
surpris ce matin je m'attendais à voir
la même chose on fera quand même à paris
c'est avec les murs je pensais serait un
petit peu plus petit peu plus souple
quand même
le souffle est terrible a soufflé t rim
quoi les arbres qui sont tombés ça des
barrières dans tous les sens pouvait
rien faire tout ce temps il fallait
attendre que tout se calme pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir faire quelque chose
ce qui me réconforte c'est capable et
j'ai c'est que évidemment s'il ya du
matériel qui tombe sur la tête des mêmes
des employés ou tout ça on n'a rien eu
donc merci mon dieu quand il ya pas mort
d'homme beau le reste c'est une question
de courage et on en a plein
ok
jésus